[Music]
we're gathered here this morning for a
very happy
occasion occasion in which the academy
recognizes the work of young people the
people who will someday be taking our
places tonight we're here to see the
best student film in the country and
honor the filmmakers we flown the
winning students in from across the
country they spent the last few days
meeting professional filmmakers and
seeing the way we make movies in
Hollywood but after seeing their movies
boy do we have something to
learn this is a very moving occasion for
members of The
Academy all 4,000 of us people in every
facet of film making once stood where
the young filmmakers we're celebrating
tonight are standing on the threshold of
their careers asking themselves am I on
the right track well these awards are
meant to say yes you're terrific you're
talented you're on your way stick with
it and go the
distance if you can be recognized by
this Academy it really says something
for
you it tells the people in the industry
that you can tell a story on film to
have an award like this validates all
the hours and hours he spent locked in
that room I would really like to address
my colleagues new filmmakers and future
filmmakers I hope that we will use our
abilities to give people choices to
bring joy but also to challenge people's
perceptions and maybe we can contribute
in some small way to bettering this
world I really think what we're looking
at
tonight is uh the harbinger of the next
years and I think that's very optimistic
I'm very pleased about
that
[Music]
please welcome the director of real
women have curves Student Academy Award
winner Patricia cardoo
welcome to the 50th annual Student
Academy Awards a lot has changed since
that first ceremony in
1973 but with all the changes over the
years in the names and numbers of
categories presented this is ultimately
about providing a platform for emerging
Global filmmakers by creating
opportunities within the industry to
Showcase their work
Student Academy Award winners have gone
on to become the legends of film making
Ley pit doctor Trey Parker and
Robert seis are just a few of the past
564 Student Academy Award winners six
who won this award twice collectively
they have 67 Academy Award nominations
and have won 15 Oscars but whether they
brought home an Academy Award later in
their careers I know that they each look
back on that moment when they won their
Student Academy Award with pride and
gratitude I know I do I won my Student
Academy Award in
1996 I received a gold medal in the
dramatic category for my UCLA thesis
film The Water carrier a movie about a
true story my father told me while
growing up in
Colombia receiving the Student Academy
Award gave me confidence I feel seen I
felt bad valued I felt validated it
helped me realize I had a voice as a
filmmaker just by being me using my
instincts my ideas and my stories it
also opened and continues to open doors
for me and it inspired me to believe
that I could keep making
films that is so fitting given that the
theme of this year's ceremony is 50
years of
inspiration bottom line we all need
validation of our work we all need the
support of our peers and of those those
who came before us and no one has ever
gotten this far without a dose of
inspiration to carry you
through and that is exactly what the
Academy of Motion Pictures Arts and
Sciences has been doing for student
filmmakers for half a century so
congratulations to everyone we look
forward to celebrating you and your work
for many years to come and now it is my
honor to introduce the CEO of the
Academy of motion pictures at and
Sciences Bill
Kramer
thank you so much Patricia I'm thrilled
to be here tonight for what we all feel
is one of the highlights of our year the
Student Academy
Awards the mission of the academy is to
connect Global audiences through their
shared love of Cinema to curate and Lead
vital and thoughtful programs about our
past present and future to celebrate all
aspects of the film industry and The
Talented diverse people who make movies
and to inspire Young Artists and to
create opportunities for communities to
engage with the film world and the
Student Academy Awards are at the heart
of this Mission you our student
filmmakers are the future of our
everchanging industry and you give us
all hope and confidence that together we
will nurture and evolve our Film
Community our future is here in this
room tonight and with your fellow
student filmmakers across the globe and
there are a lot of great student
filmmakers out there this year we had a
record number of submissions
2,443 almost 700 more than in the past
and they came from
726 schools from around the world it's
amazing I
know
thank
you this program is amazing and that was
a record as well and because of that
record number of submissions a special
thanks must go out to our 640 judges our
Academy members who give their time and
their talent to watch all of that
extraordinary work I would like to take
this moment to thank some of the leaders
involved with the Student Academy Awards
starting with our amazing governor and
chair of the education and Outreach
committee Brooke
Bretton Brooke Champions all of the
Academy's incredible Talent Development
programs I'd also like to thank Peggy Ry
and the entire Student Academy Awards
executive
committee none of this would be possible
without Peggy's leadership and the
executive committee's leadership and of
course I want to thank our amazing
Academy staff whose commitment and
dedication to this work helps us shine a
light on the Next Generation
specifically kendri Carter Shan Guthrie
Hector Garcia and Chris
Zino yeah they're the
best
in addition many of our presenters
tonight are Student Academy Awards
alumni so to all of you welcome home and
to all of our filmmakers here tonight
you know that you are already winners
but tonight you'll find out if you will
receive the bronze silver or gold but on
behalf of everybody at the Academy
congratulations we are thrilled for you
hope you guys yeah
please
have an incredible night tonight uh and
I'm thrilled that we can now start our
show our first award category is
animation have a great
[Music]
night
boom is about a stupid couple of Birds
trying to escape the terrible explosion
of the volcano from their
island and trying to survive with their
eggs we wanted to place some characters
who are more or less stupid uh in front
of a huge catastrophe but they very
heart of the short film is this satire
of human nature and how we are reacting
when we are facing situations that are
overwhelming us for me the movie is
really personal because the background
the vegetation and our character was
inspired by my native
Island in indan we are a small team and
everyone can actually participate in the
storytelling having different voices
just making the story grow well first
goal was just to make people love we had
a lot of fun during the prodution
laughing
smiling I want to keep putting stores in
kids eyes because it's the most
beautiful thing we can make I want to
keep making movies cuz I've never been
so happy in my life it's like a fairy
tale like I live my family my friend uh
my Island six years ago and now and here
it's a confirmation about our skill like
we can test story yeah just do it let's
[Music]
try let Clips is a film about the Sun
and the Moon some message that the world
will soon end and so Humanity decide to
send an Eno to negotiate a solution the
film is really about making the best of
what we have life contemplating every
aspect of it and every be of it we had
like an idea of the message we wanted to
convey but everyone we show it to
interpreted the message in a different
way e comy or friendship or love with
the children that's what we like about
it that it's not like very sharp
everyone can project what he wants we
really listen to each other really
really cared about everyone and I think
can feel it as well winning a student
Academy Award it's really great remember
the most important part F making sharing
with with other and it's always a big
surprise tell you the like it's very
important when you're doing movie to
share feelings with people I think
that's what want as
filmaker something I learned working
with this great team is that you have to
have fun I had the best year with the G
making the world I think that's what
made the our great to wake up and share
ideas all day and create something from
the start it was a great time and I
think we can see that in the
[Music]
movie The name's poppy I'm a little
cocky I'm starting up Don't Stop
mey keep it down it's time for school on
spaghetti is about a young teenage girl
who is an aspiring rapper and she goes
on a journey to learn it's cool to be
kind and that she can still be a good
rapper and be kind and be nice to her
friends at the same time it comes from a
personal story in my own life which is
that my best friend um actually commit
suicide about 10 years ago and then
following that another close friend of
mine commit suicide as well that kind of
got me thinking about how we treat each
other and the way that we speak to each
other and if people can come away and
just have this idea and this feeling of
looking after your friends and looking
out for each other and lifting each
other up then that's the job well done
in my book stop motion for me was my way
into animation I always knew that I
wanted to make films but I was never
very techy but stop motion was an
accessible way to like pick up a bit of
P the scene get an old camera and start
fing the stories that I wanted to tell
come back when your Rhymes aren
work winning a student Academy Award for
me is just incredible it is it's so
surreal I come from a pretty small
overlooked town called Black pool here
in the UK so for me I want to like look
into these little stories and the people
that I grew up with and the characters
that I've known throughout my life and
shine a good light on them I don't think
anyone from Blackpool has ever won any
kind of Academy Award so it feels really
special to be able to represent people
like me and stories like mine and to the
kids growing up around here look if
you've got a dream and if there's
something that you want to do go for it
work really hard and you can absolutely
achieve it like there's no reason that
we can't you know break our way into any
industry that we want to be um seeing in
she's the winner of the 2021 domestic
animation gold medal they're animators
and co-directors of the Super Mario
Brothers movie please welcome Sujin Kim
Aaron horth and Michael
[Applause]
jelen wow this is so cool
Sujin yes it's so great to be up here
with you you won a student Academy Award
what's that like oh thank you for asking
that eron no one asked because that was
during coid 19 pandemic in 2021 during
the lockdown I received this media core
DM link from the Student Academy Awards
and I was told that it will be an
informal interview with all the finalist
to my surprise when I loged on well the
legendary filmmaker Pete do doctor was
there for me and announced my film this
uh Kell Arts thesis un forgotten headman
award the Student Academy Award it was
so real it was
amazing yeah I'm so grateful today to
have this opportunity you know to
standing on this stage with you guys
instead of sitting in front of my
computer in Pama bottoms so now I have a
question for Michael so what is it like
to have a top gring film at the fox
office it's
cool but I never met Pete doctor so you
got us there
yeah we should probably tell this year's
winners which award they won let's give
it up for tonight's bronze medal winner
for animation Lisa Kenny from mum
spaghetti National film and television
School United
[Music]
Kingdom
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks everyone I'm uh Missing the Great
British breake off to be here so it's a
pleasure to hang out with you all
we're sorry to inform you but your
application has been unsuccessful at
this time dear Lisa we love your work
but we've decided to go with someone
with more
experience who are you and please stop
sending us plasticy models in the
post these are the kinds of emails that
I've been getting since leaving school
at 16 years old and then five weeks ago
I got an email that said
congratulations congratulations on
having your film mom spaghetti selected
as a student Academy Award winner it's
the coolest film we've ever seen please
come here have your
autograph I'm only joking about that
last
bit I've had more knockbacks than I can
count but I've kept my hopes up and I've
kept working hard regardless all for
that email five weeks ago all for this
moment and I'm here today representing
people from small towns with Big Dreams
you can achieve whatever you want to
achieve um in this world and don't ever
let anyone tell you
otherwise thank
you
thank you first and foremost to the
academy for having me um and for an
incredible week out here in La it really
has been life-changing thank you to
Robert bradbrook for being the first
person to open the door for me and let
me have a little peek inside to Lizzie
Hobs Kim na beex haves John Osborne and
osbert Parker uh for your tuition and
guidance over the last few years thanks
to the nfts the best film School in the
world um thank you to my spaghetti team
these lovely people without whom we
wouldn't be standing here today
uh and they are Emma grisette Jack Marie
Martina buendia Silva uh world famous
cinematographer Toby Lloyd Harry Foster
Hannah Barnet Luke stronck Luke barfa
Mara cha Danny peoples Gemma wils Sophie
foxley Eve banister Aiden Mo and the
nfts model makers uh to my fellow
animators who got me through the nfts
with endless love and laughter they are
rich Flavia Maria Amy Ross Kira Donnie
Sara and Tanya
thank you to Andy simanowski and Mark
Baker for the mentorship and thank you
to baa for the scholarship and
support um thank you to my fairy art mom
Elaine for not telling me off when I
drew on the tables at school shout out
to my girls from Leeds and my Palatine
crew back at home who are all watching
um for cheering me on all the way and
for not getting mad when I chose
animating overnights out to my auntie
Isabelle Alan Miranda Lucy and Connor to
Martina for the love support
encouragement kindness and Care massive
thank you to my dad who's watching back
at home who's been telling me this time
next year for as far back as I can
remember the time is finally here Dad um
thank you to my mom who has sat no doubt
crying in the audience um for letting me
graffiti my bedroom as a teenager and
for getting me all the art supplies on
my Christmas list year after year thank
you to my big brother and best friend
um so thanks man for showing me all of
the best cartoons growing up um and
telling everyone who'd ever listened to
him about his little sister's animation
this is for us
mate and finally for my best friend
Chris Karma to whom this film is
dedicated uh we spoke about this day
when we were 13 years old we made it pal
they say that people from Blackpool
don't win Oscars well we do
[Applause]
now
congratulations to the whole team from
mum spaghetti big
team and now here is this year's silver
Medal winner for animation Cesar Luton
Asel Pas clayon Bailey from diplomacy de
eclips mopa 3D animation School
[Applause]
[Music]
France
[Applause]
[Music]
so before we start we are a team of five
and only four of us could be here so the
last one you've been been able to seen a
glimpse of his lovely face later his
name is ashel Pas he's an amazing friend
and the film wouldn't have been the same
with that him so I'd love to thank the
academy uh it's been an amazing evening
and honestly an amazing week and we've
been able to meet so many talented
people I look forward to see the film
you're going to make guys so shout out
to you and yes thanks a
lot thank
you I would like to to thank the our
school mopa for this uh five amazing
years with this team thank
you we also like to thank t for the
music which add a lot of dep to our film
and also Pier Duan Beno for the sound
effect and nataniel Williams for the
amazing performance as a voice
actor
[Laughter]
I'd like to thanks our family our
friends uh everyone who support us and
um every people who took the time to
watch our movie thank you
everyone
wow here is this year's Gold Award
winner for
animation
Gabriel
Roman Yanik ja
for eeken images
[Applause]
[Music]
pranks
[Applause]
[Music]
wow um thank you uh we are deeply
honored and proud to receive this award
it's a huge accomplishment for our team
to see that all the work all the
sleepless night we put in this short
film is rewarded by the academy uh we
would like to thank first matis Marshall
who made the original score secondly our
families and friends who helped us and
supported us throughout the production
our school of course e called the Noel
image and its educational team for
pushing us beyond our limits me
distribution for the great work that I
have done Distributing and taking care
of our short film and of course we want
to thank the academy and its members a
million times for this award for their
consideration and for the incredible
week we spent here we met amazing people
we had a lot of fun discovering Los
Angeles and its surrounding with you and
we hope that we'll be able to meet you
all again in the future this movie
started as the joke
and it made it here so uh I'll
say keep laughing uh it maybe can take
you here one day uh Mercy Buu and have a
nice
[Laughter]
evening
[Music]
my documentary duad is a parallel story
about two musicians a MAA award-winning
musician bright shin and his very
talented pianist daughter fi being a
musician was his only way to embrace his
Destiny but it is a path that his
talented 11 year-old daughter isn't sure
that she wants herself actually the
story is very personal to me I was a
classical pianist who studied piano at a
very young age from my musician mom and
never thought I would become a
documentary filmmaker and sometimes when
I was practicing the piano and I always
used my imagination about visuals and
stories to make my practicing more
interesting and engaging making
documentaries is a very important way
for me to communicate with people when I
play the piano I sometimes I would be
mad at myself playing the wrong not
notes however when I hold the camera my
heart is full of compassion and
curiosity congratulations winning Awards
remind me that if you do not give up and
improvise like just music and find your
own Rhythm and Pace you can make your
dream come
[Music]
true
till we find them is a short documentary
that depicts the tireless Church of the7
CA families in Mexico to find their
missing loved ones the film centers on
selo who founded the collective 3 years
after her daughter Ruby went missing and
since then more than 350 families have
joined the collective I metel at a
women's Day event in New York City in
March of 2022 and she stood up in the
steps of the New York City public
library and started telling her story in
Spanish like many in Mexico I grew up
with the idea that one shouldn't speak
about the topic of missing people
because it could get you in trouble or
because it's a dangerous topic that we
should avoid and I was so moved that
after she finished speaking I went up to
her and I told her that I promised that
I would help her tell her story I
started making films when I was six and
what inspires me to keep making films is
to stay grounded and connect thing for
the world because when I'm filming when
I'm editing when I'm making a film is
when I feel most alive and grounded and
connected with others it feels amazing
to be a student Academy Award winner I
feel so grateful that the story is
getting attention this movie was created
and is driven by the unconditional love
of the families and especially the
mothers so what I hope that people take
away after watching it is their strength
their courage and their Showcase of so
so much love and what they're willing to
do to find
[Music]
them the documentary wings of dust is
about Vidal merma who is an indigenous
journalist from Peru who fights against
the pollution of the water in his
country and in his land the main reason
why I connected to the story is because
Vidal first of all is a father more than
a journalist he does everything for Eric
to make sure Eric is going to have a
beautiful future with clean water in his
L funny fact is that I learned Spanish
two weeks before going to Peru watching
narcos on Netflix so I know I knew some
bed worth the first week was extremely
tricky I think the breaking point for me
happened when during a birthday party I
had to make a speech in Spanish and
that's where my confidence uh boosted a
lot CU they understood me as a filmmaker
my biggest goal is to share the message
that is to believe in the impossible but
this is why I'm really inspired by
people who usually are in the backstage
who usually no one cares about or
they're not consider important but they
are the ones that at the end of the day
would be crucial for important fights so
the necessity with this film was to
bring practical examples to life like
the story of Videl and I hope with this
documentary we can Inspire more young
people for a more practical call to
[Music]
action they are the 2022 Student Academy
Award alternative experimental Gold
Medal winner and he's the director of
the 2017 Student Academy award
documentary Gold Medal winner please
welcome Olivia peace and Brad
[Applause]
Bailey those were some wonderful films
huh Olivia yeah absolutely I've been
about to cry like several times and I
want to tell you you're a beautiful
crowd this evening so it's it's an honor
and a privilege to be here thank
you and so Brad you won the student
Academy Award six years ago for
directing hail and I think you were also
the first African-American to win gold
in the category for a US
director what kind of an impact did
winning have on you well Olivia thank
you um that was it was a big deal it was
a it was a big deal right
sorry um but uh thank you thank you
thank
you um but the thing is the most
important thing is I feel like I sort of
got inducted into a fan family as you
all this evening will be so welcome to
the family and just welcome to a
wonderful community of people who share
your hopes share your dreams and share
your challenges as well so we're going
to be here with you through whatever you
go through so I want to welcome you to
the family and thank you for being thank
you all all and the great support you've
had here tonight thank you thank
you and Olivia uh you won last year for
your film against reality what was your
experience like um I remember it being
terrifying uh I remember I was super
worried I was going to drop the trophy
or trip up the
stage um but then in the end it ended up
being all about Community right like you
were saying um it was a real opportunity
for people to be able to find me um some
of these people are in the audience with
us tonight and it's been really I think
such a blessing so super excited for you
all Best Is Yet To Come yes it is than
thank
you and now it's time to get to this
year's documentary awards first is the
bronze medal winner for documentary
congratulations to Jean chapiro for
hasta aasta
anos till we found them Columbia
University go bear go tiger go
[Applause]
lions
[Music]
[Applause]
oh this is too tall for me I'm too short
give me a
second can you hear me okay cool um wow
this is so surreal um I'm kind of losing
my voice CU I'm so excited um thank you
so much for the academy for this honor
this is so amazing and so surreal I'm so
honored to be in this position thank you
to Columbia University and all of my
professors who believed in me and taught
me that I am capable and worthy of
telling important stories that need to
be heard and deserve to be
heard um thank you so much to all of my
my crew say that and you who are here um
and all of the crew back in Mexico that
believed in this film and you poured all
of your heart into this film thank you
so much much
gracias um I want to thank my family
especially my parents
ma um your unconditional love allow me
to portray the unconditional love that
the arav Cordova family suffer their
missing loved ones and because of you I
was able to see it in them um
thank you to the Arisa and Cordova
families for allowing me to tell your
stories and most of all thank you to you
araseli thank you for allowing me to
tell your story thank you for your
courage Your Love and your
strength thank you for teaching me to
never never give up and to fight for
what I believe in this is for all the
families around the world looking for a
missing loved one in Mexico and around
the world people are still looking and
we believe in you and in your fight
thank you so much for this honor and for
spotlighting this film thank you to the
academy thank
you
you that was beautiful um and so now the
silver medal for documentary goes to Lou
way Shen for duet New York York
[Applause]
[Music]
University
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
yeah thank you so much
to yeah thank you you are the
best okay thank you to the academy for
this incredible honor
when I did the interview with you I was
asked what inspire you to be a
documentary
filmmaker if I have been asked this
question in the past I would have said
because because I'm an image lover and
my trood dream was to be a painter so I
wanted to tell stories uh like
officially but at the time
you know at that
moment the words came out of my mouth
surprised me I said it's
music W then um at the moment all the
memories I have about music just emerged
in my mind all the happiness sadness and
joy and
anger so like then I realized I have had
this incredible and crazy love for
music um so which like shaped who I am
today and you
know just just allow me to tell stories
the documentary film making ignited my
passion so like I really like holding
the camera I like the fing because it's
my way to communicate with people and
myself with compassion and love and as I
stand here I wanted to like give thanks
to my mom who is a musician who really
like firm beli that I would become a
musician but later on support me to be a
documentary filmmaker
anyway I wanted to give thanks to my
professors at NYU ppec masar is here
with us
today and also my crew members
and my
friend you
know
like your encourage and Faith like you
know give me a lot of encourage and the
faith just like the lighthouse guiding
the boat on the open like dark sea that
I really appreciate that I would
dedicate this documentary to my
protagonist Bri Shen and his daughter f
bran trusted me and decided to work with
me on our first Zoom meeting What A
Brave and Bold
decision and uh you know finally I
believe that what faith face choice is
and she's on her way on her journey to
find her passion and her freedom and I
believe she will continue to be a
wonderful person and thank you so much
everyone
Miss don't forget your price got you yes
don't forget this you're going to need
that you're going to need
that and the Student Academy Award gold
Medal winner for documentary goes to
Georgio gioto for wings of dust New York
[Applause]
[Music]
University
[Applause]
[Music]
thank
you so I still uh remember this
moment I was driving a night with uh
Vidal me and him middle of nowhere in
Peru it was complete dark and we came
back from a really challenging shooting
day and I remember in this moment I
thought Within Myself looking at Videl I
thought wow no matter what even though
he risk his life every day he's still
the most
resilient and positive person I ever met
in my
life and you know usually as documentary
filmmakers we go to far places we meet
people that are in a less comfortable
position than we are and we think we
need to help those people but Vidal um
his family his community actually helped
me they changed my life because they
told me things like love
empathy and
resilience so I think today Videl uh is
Spire me so much is Part all of us to
never turn the other way when the other
person eats in
need
and so with this I really want to thank
the academy because they help viel being
here today with
getting his visa to come to the states
so I'm so
happy I really want to thank my
professors that truly believed in me
were so critical uh there Marsha Rock
Jason Samons Jason Malone I want to
thank my amazing crew starting with my
incredible composer Sasha Blan that
truly gave a
voice to
the to the film with a lot of
sensitivity my colorist Andreas
sabatelli my sound mixer Fabricio
Evangelista I would like to thank one
special person for me Eliza Minik that
truly um you know show me light in
really dark moment when I thought this
film wasn't worth anything
I would like to thank my family my
friends watching me from Rome in Italy
uh my good friends and supporter uh Ben
pru Camila Hall and Jing galano that has
been uh supporting me and guiding me a
lot and I if it's possible like vid to
say a few words thank you so
much
[Music]
for
Li
I'm not a translator as You'
seen but I will try to express in the
best way so he want want to thanks God
for this opportunity V said is a simple
journalist but he does all he can to
protect our environment because there's
no way he can stand the human rights
violation that he see in front of his
eyes every day and his strongest
motivation is Eric which is his kid and
he really wants to work hard and risk
his life to make sure that Eric is going
to have a better future than what VI is
leaving now and he will keep fighting
and he thanks everybody for the
[Applause]
[Laughter]
support
powerful um and this next category is a
bit different from the others in that we
shine the spotlight on just one
winner
[Applause]
W just like you last year what prompted
you to make a film that falls under the
alternative experimental Banner since
you also make liveaction narrative
films it's really funny actually when I
first moved to LA uh one of my friends
pulled up a Vimeo link okay um and
showed me an opera and my friend told me
that this film had won the experimental
category at the Student Academy Awards
and I was like I didn't even know that
that was something that was
possible um and I think that's really
what experimental alternative films do
for people is they expand your
understanding of what's possible
absolutely so uh let's look let's now
take a look at this year's um um this
year's alternative winner thank
[Music]
you
I'm Leo baren I went to American Film
Institute and I made a film called skin
skin is a symbolic and a visual metaphor
of a woman who's transitioning into a
man she discovers that she has to let go
of who she is in order to become herself
the story is kind of a representation of
my own Journey I've never seen anything
so far that actually describes the
feeling of having that journey in a
short film I think we all to a certain
degree are trying to figure out who we
are by making this film I want people to
get in touch with something deeper in
themselves and maybe question themselves
about who they are or are they true to
themselves as a filmmaker I Can Shed
light on topics that hasn't received
that much attention and trying to
portray that from A New Perspective
whatever I make whatever I do all I want
to do ultimately is to uplift and
Inspire winning the Student Academy
Awards means everything because my
vision was clear I got to the end and
I'm happy with the result because I was
listening to that voice inside of me as
long as you work hard and you put in
effort there's nothing that can stop
you
so now please welcome to the stage this
year's winner for the category of
alternative experimental Leo baren for
skin from the American Film Institute
now you can come
[Applause]
up
[Music]
your
problem thank you
I'm deeply deeply honored to receive
this
award thank you to um the academy and
its members for recognizing our
film um a special thanks to Shan and the
entire team for their dedication to the
Student Academy and all the winners it's
been such an incredible experience so
thank you I'm truly thankful for The
Talented team that you see beside me um
a special thanks to my actor Leo Mel who
couldn't be here today um and to my
producer and partner Ela Chen Kaya um
who believed in me since day one
um yeah she had my
back um so I share this award with all
of them um I want to thank the American
Film Institute and a special thanks to
Sarah Ros Samco Sandra
Hansen and Steven litill for your
support and for allowing us to make such
an ambitious project I'm deeply grateful
for my family um for their love and
support throughout my life and for
encouraging my artistic abilities I want
to thank my mother who is no longer with
us without her I wouldn't be um the
artist that I am today lastly I want to
thank my spiritual teacher Kaa without
him I wouldn't be um here today I think
either so in 2011 I embarked on a
personal Journey transitioning from
female to male from a young age I
express myself as male but as puberty
changed my body I try to conform to
societal Norms the increasing internal
conflict made me realize that my inner
and outer worlds were not in
harmony
this journey became the inspiration
behind skin a film that touches on the
struggles we all face in accepting
ourselves we all have felt the weight of
expectations the fear of being
misunderstood and the pressure to fit in
it creates a barrier within ourselves
similar to our skin separating our inner
selves from the external world when we
dare to peel away these layers by
questioning our own identity we open the
door to self self-discovery true change
starts within in a world that often
focuses on appearance over substance I
hope we can move past this and learn to
see each other for who we are beneath
our skin Beyond color gender
disabilities and sexuality by choosing
kindness empathy and understanding we
can Inspire each
other we can Inspire others to embrace
their individuality without fear of
judgment as a filmmaker we have the
wonderful opportunity to capture the
essence of our shared human experiences
and put it onto the screen it allows us
to raise our voices share our stories
and break down the barriers that
separates
us this is one of the many reasons why I
chose to be in this industry so this
award is a proof that I'm on the right
path so again thank you so much to the
academy for this award thank you
he is last year's Student Academy Award
bronze medal winner in the narrative
category please welcome Freddy
[Applause]
McDonald it's honestly such an honor to
be here I was getting choked up
backstage I was like I hope I can
deliver this this speech but it's also
an honor because last year I wasn't able
to make it I was shooting my first
feature but today I'm excited to talk
about the EMA green seal and uh
sustainability and climate action are
way of protecting the environment for
tomorrow when I made my film shedding
angels I made a promise to the entire
production team that we would do
everything in our power to be
sustainable on set and I was so honored
when we received the first EMA green
seal for students EMA stands for the
environmental media Association which
has a set of guidelines for green
production practices our team car pooed
recycled props used less energy had
reusable water bottles on set and
reduced carbon emissions we are so
excited to announce that starting next
year we'll acknowledge Student Academy
Award films that also earn the EMA green
seal for sustainable
production
the great part about sustainability is
that there's something we can each do as
individuals and as an artistic Community
all of us are very excited to know that
going forward the academy will be
recognizing and supporting green
production for the Next Generation it is
such a fulfilling process and I hope you
all strive to incorporate it on your
next set I'm so glad I did so thank you
very
much
[Music]
need
up
the movie is about police officer Nancy
who has the job to devote a family to
Albania again and the whole thing ends
in a
dilemma in 2016 a lot of migrants came
from Syria to Austria because of the
Syrian and Civil War and I think the
Austrian government didn't make very
very well decisions which people they
choose to leave Austria and which people
they deported so this is something my
movie is about to be honest it's like a
feeling bad movie and I wanted to show
the kind of dilemma of our system here
in Europe between doing your job and
knowing that your job is the wrong
thing I'm honest with the topics I work
with and I only work on topics I believe
in or I did a lot of research as
research for my film I worked on a
police station talked a lot to the
police officers I also worked in a kind
of refugee camp so I got both
sides I want to keep making films
because for me it's the precises art to
declare my own problems on the things
that are touching
me
[Music]
Pap Revisited is the story about Tia
it's the 20th anniversary of her
father's death and she'd rather be
anywhere else than home with her mother
and brother as she's planning to leave
back to Oslo suddenly there's a knock on
the door and the man who's there is her
father what do they do as they meet a
man they've missed for so long and
that's what the film is
about I lost my own dad when I was 13
years old so I had a very early
understanding of death and how fragile
life is and I think what I look for in
the films I make is a kind of Beauty in
that time and these moments we have
together
[Laughter]
ideally we want the audience to leave a
cinema and call their mom or call their
dad and say I love you because you never
know when you won't get that chance
anymore winning a student Academy Award
is such an encouragement to keep going I
have so many rejections from funding and
festivals so this is just this enormous
encouragement that it's not for nothing
this whole
[Music]
Endeavor our film is about yela a photo
journalist from Serbia that is being
threatened because of her work and she
has to flee with her little daughter to
Germany but as soon as she continues to
work she's again being a target of right
spring
attacks
the attacks on media professionals is an
international topic and it's a worldwide
threat we take it for granted just to
read the news but what it means to get
those news for the people and who is
behind it and who's working for it I
think this was really important for me
to
[Music]
show I'm very interested in political
relevant stories and making them
emotionally approachable because I think
we can read the newspapers but it's a
different thing if we are as an audience
involved in a very personal story and a
personal faith of
someone to win a student Academy Award
it's
unbelievable we wanton a student
Oscar it can maybe be an entrance to a
hopefully promising career we never know
but what makes me happy that people want
to see the film and are interested in
the film because this is why I make
films I want them to be seen by as many
people as
possible please welcome the 1982 Gold
Medal winner in the dramatic category
Kang kapas and the 2017 narrative Gold
Medal winner Kevin Wilson
[Applause]
Jr wow wow it's uh it's been six years
since I've been on this stage and it's
brought back a lot of memories being
here how about for you it's been a few
more years since I've been on this stage
but but this is such an inspiring night
and all the films are so amazing so
absolutely great Ken you've had such an
amazing career in the years since you
won the gold medal for your film For
Heaven's Sake how did winning that gold
medal have an impact on
you you know winning the award gave me
the confidence to pursue the thing I
love and that's telling stories with
pictures and you know the business it's
unpredictable it's
unforgiving but what's carried the day
for me over the years is a passion for
the craft of directing and that passion
kicked into high gear on this stage when
I received the Student Academy
Award and uh and Kevin you're win for my
nephew EMT uh was more recent so what
what has that led to in the past few
years well um it led to me getting my
first Oscar
nomination which which kickstarted my
career and opened the door for me to be
able to use art to take care of my
family and I think that's all we want as
artists to be able to wake up in the
morning put our shoes on and go create
fantastic
fantastic okay well let's let's learn
the names of the great new voices of a
generation the Student Academy Award
bronze medal winner in the narrative
category is Tamara danic for ISTA
Hamburg Media School
[Music]
[Applause]
Germany
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I hope it doesn't fall
down so hi everybody body um thank you
so much Academy this is crazy this is
just wonderful thank you so much for
this appreciation and this award and I
also want to thank all those amazing
filmmakers sitting here in the front row
um it's an honor to share stage with you
I'm so glad that I could meet all of you
this week and um I want to
thank yes
Applause um I want to thank h Media
School Mo film fund ba broadcaster and
the young Talent Foundation Berlin and
of course a special thanks and a big
Applause to the crazy cast and crew that
we have here thank you so much for all
your support and all your
work and also H thanks to the cast in
Serbia and in Germany who isn't here
with us
tonight there are so many people that I
would like to name but I think I would
stand here till tomorrow and you will
probably fall asleep s
so um I try to dedicate this precious
time now to the people we made our film
about to the journalists so I want to
thank uh all the journalists in Serbia
and in Germany that supported us with
the project and who shared their
personal stories with us because
everything that Ena is telling about is
kind of sadly based on true events and
based on their
stories in the past seven days seven
journalists were killed in Gaz and
Lebanon among them Isam abdalah and
ibraim
HFI two Iranian journalists nilar hamedi
and elah mohamadi are
imprisoned and American Russian
journalist alsu kurmasheva is taken
hostage by Russia and the list goes on
and goes on and goes on freedom of the
press is not something we should take
for granted I mean fake news conspiracy
theories are spreading faster and
faster and I think it should be our
responsibility as a society to
ensure someone has to wake
[Laughter]
up okay let's get back to serus please
so I think it's our responsibility that
we have to ensure that journalists can
do their job under secure working
conditions because without journalist
there can be no free reporting and the
threat to the freedom of the press is a
threat to our
democracy so I really want to dedicate
this award to all the brave journalists
in the world that risk their lives daily
for the freedom of the press and freedom
of the speech thank you so much and have
a lovely evening
[Applause]
thanks
[Music]
the Student Academy Award silver Medal
winner in the narrative category is Ian
Igan stronic Forbes for Revisited the
Norwegian Film School in
[Applause]
[Music]
Norway
[Applause]
[Music]
I would like to thank the academy for
This Magnificent honor you have bestowed
upon us during our shoot in the dark of
winter in a freezing cold house built in
the 19th century who would have imagined
would be reunited here in sunny
La I want to thank DP Kina seral Cel for
constantly chasing excellence and
achieving it again and again production
designer Brun duxot for creating a
living breathing space which inspired
the story at every
turn editor Natasha ramlov lensen for
critical loving eye but never lost sight
of What mattered most sound assigner
Martis Lee for weaving the atmospheres
of grief and ourne into a Harmony VFX
Rickard Vin clar for masterfully
crafting the images needed for our
climax producer t yandal a uniting force
of nature to whom this film owes every
frame of its being and to those not here
tonight co-writer Lena silag composer
Martin Olsen have arrest of the
outstanding cast and
[Applause]
crew a big thanks to teachers staff and
fellow students of a Norwegian Film
School our sponsor fabl and
crowdfunders Revisited is a story about
family and grief but more importantly
about
love I would like to thank my late
father whose memory sustains and
inspires me your spirit will never
[Applause]
die but more
importantly my mother who has encouraged
and believed in me every step of a way
finally my girlfriend my sister family
and friends for me cinema is at its most
beautiful when it connects with us
emotionally it is a reminder of how
alike we all really are we would do well
to remember this thank you so much
[Applause]
to so there have been a lot of Wonder
ful awards given out tonight and now
it's time for the final
one the Student Academy Award gold medal
in the narrative
category is Mark gorer for invisible
border Film Academy VI
[Applause]
[Music]
Austria
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
yeah wow uh thanks a lot for
this uh I'm really
happy I really tried to uh learn this
but I'm
completely yeah
so uh first of all thanks to Academy for
for having me here I had really a great
week also a great week with you guys so
it was I hope it would be endless so
um uh big thanks to my uh actors uh Lulu
Natalie Lavino
Alex um very big thanks to my dop Marie
teres tomt we see us now for Wow uh for
the first time since long she was
pregnant in the six months while she was
shooting the movie so
wow and there are some few guys I want
to introduce to labin not Morino
maximilan d uh Maas havner who did the
sound design we had a lot of nice time
in your studio also Alexander Al we had
a lot of nice time in your studio Lara
who made the sound recording um and uh
uh also thanks to um Tommy Leo nadeli
who couldn't be here today and vosa uh
brightener Lupin
so um
yeah I'm think last of all thanks to my
uh uh my my girlfriend Veronica har who
did the costume design and my son Corin
he's very fresh so uh yeah thank you
thank you so
[Applause]
much please welcome the chair of the
Student Academy Awards executive
committee producer Branch member and
Academy Award winner Peggy
Ry
hey
everybody wow I don't know about you but
I found this to be an incredibly
inspiring and moving night and I really
want to thank all of our incredible
filmmakers you know thank you for the
light you bring into the world through
your work it's important and I'm so
grateful to be here to be a witness to
it so so we very much look forward to
welcoming you back as
alums um I also want to take a moment to
give a big special thank you to our CEO
Bill creamer and Academy president Janet
Yang for the continued and valuable
support of this Legacy
[Applause]
program and to our 640 judges tum
640 a big shout out to all of you for
Lending your time and talented eye to
screening all our films and to my fellow
[Applause]
Yeahs and to my fellow executive
committee members for the Student
Academy Awards thank you for your
tireless support of this next generation
of Industry talent and for your valuable
guidance of this program and of course
thanks to all our presenters as well as
the academy team who've been involved in
producing this event and that brings me
to helping highlight some of our other
unsing unsung heroes the people that
these films have helped create tonight
which is all of your crew the directors
received the awards tonight that's true
for having a vision and seeing it
through to completion but none of them
could be here tonight without their
dedicated crew members who are often
fellow students
[Applause]
so so we would like to take um a moment
tonight to let tonight's directors
Express their thanks once more for the
invaluable support they get from their
Crews
page had an amazing team everyone across
the board just put 110% into the to have
a good crew that hold your back as a
director is so important so many people
so it's always hard to start before I
want to thank my producer who is also my
partner Ela Chaya also MOA Wen my
production designer we would like to
thank Co directors Char and Lori
pero and Mar who made the music on the
team there was also AEL M and S there
are both
direct is this my producer Emma grette
my DP Toby lyd composer Hannah Barnet
our sound designer Luke barfa who went
on to win an award for the sound design
Harry our editor Martina buendia Silva
and of course Jack Marie our amazing rer
I was so honored and lucky to work with
really talented
filmmakers musicians colorists
cinematographers all over the world I
want to thank Michael Co producer and DP
Cesar Chito sound repord Rafa hi my
editor perer the colorist Serio cero all
of the professors at Columbia University
and I also want to thank the piter
center for supporting this film and
giving me the funds to get here the
first person I like to thank is Vidal
for trusting me Sasha my composer my
professor Mara but also Jason samels J
Malone I want to thank Mar teres the DP
of the project my professor Mel hanik my
girlfriend of the custom designer
Veronica Jenny BL did the makeup Matias
Harner and Lisa Maria monos salign Lucas
roati did the production Alexander NOA
made the edit Lisa sh she did the
sponsoring for our movie so thanks a lot
Lisa I would like to thank uh first of
all my core team from uni the dop andr
stman the screenwriter David lawence and
producer Christian Z and I definitely
also want to thank Nik Rosman the great
main actress you should definitely cast
her the whole team knows I love and
adore them for their effort but there is
of course one person who's been through
it the whole way and that is producer
tur yandall there was a point during the
production where I said Tu you're
amazing what can I do to thank you for
all you've done and she said give me an
Oscar so to
uh if you're watching this in the LA
here's the Oscar which you asked me for
in 2021 we made good on the
[Applause]
promise well folks here we are we just
about have wrapped up the 50th count it
50 50th Student Academy Awards so just a
quick few points of business I've been
asked to tell this year's winners to
please join us downstairs for a group
photo on the red carpet after we close
up here also a welcome to everyone to
join this year's winning filmmakers
downstairs for a post ceremony post
ceremony
celebration at the same time as that's
going on we will be screening the gold
medal winning films up here right after
we head on out so to close out let's
hear some final words from our alumni
about what this year's winner ERS have
to look forward to thank
you 5 years ago I was sitting right
where you are sitting well probably not
right where but somewhere around there
uh so congratulations it's a great honor
and I know you're all going to go on to
do great things when hadn't been for the
student Oscar putting me in front of the
Academy Awards my whole trajectory would
have been much different it opened a lot
of doors many doors so many doors it
launched my career the big boost my
career I want to welcome you to the
Student Academy Awards V Reinhardt
winning a student Academy Awards changed
my life it's a spotlight for your talent
a boost for your career ex set me on my
career path but I continued to be
staying I was already working at Disney
feature animation and by winning this
award I was promoted to animate you got
me my representation helped me find new
collaborators and new projects to work
with influential people in the industry
it made it easier to connect with
producers agents Distributors and it
very Ted to filmmaker friends an
industry leaders who I still collaborate
with and has also helped people become
curious and interested in what I'm
working on I met so many people who were
interested in my vision which led to
financing for the projects that I wanted
to make it gave me credibility and
momentum to finish my first feature even
Hillary Swank agreed to Executive
produce and star in my film 1114 while
winning the Student Academy Award made
an incredible difference in my career I
was able to have a mentor from pixer
that is a dream come true I went from
doing freelance animation to working on
feature films video games commercials I
became a studio trailer editor for over
30 years it's led to my first paid job
as a television director so y doors
either at sin in the past or at Apple TV
right now it Sparks so much good a
career friends I might not otherwise
have met and most important a purposeful
life it has given me the belief and
confidence that I needed com out a film
School reinforced my decision to change
careers and to stick through all the
hard time it was inspiring me to
continue making films so it's so hard
because he boosts your confidence in
doing what you think you're good for it
gave me confidence in my work as a
director as a filmmaker it gave me conf
that I have a boys there are so many
voices out there so it's important to
believe that yours is unique and is
necessary in the world he told me that
when you strongly believe in a story by
trusting your gods and following your
values you can make everything happen
the award gave me a confidence in my own
identity as a filmmaker made a huge
difference when I was 27 and about to
move across the country and feeling
terrified of the future and you now have
one of the greatest support system in
the world which is the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences and now don't
stop working hard anything has the
opportunity of being great if you decide
to make it so congratulations I wish you
all good health and good fortune in your
cinematic Pursuits congratulations to
all the students congratulations over in
congratulations to all the
winners I'm sorry apologies to the
editor who has to put this all together
all right uh take care